[Música]
y es momento de hablar de salud aquí en
directo a América de France 24 ya nos
acompaña en el estudio más Romero sala
buenos días Rosa cómo estás bien marco
en qué vamos a empezar hoy esta Crónica
de salud pues empezamos en Perú
básicamente porque el país está
atravesando el peor brote de dengue de
la última década de semanas que están en
alerta epidemiológica recordemos que
esta enfermedad se transmite por más por
mosquitos no es el vector que transmite
el dengue y traemos las cifras de la
situación en la que estamos son 130.000
casos sólo en 2023 detectados de los
cuales más de 37.000 son niños y también
se han superado ya los 200 fallecidos
para poner estas cifras en contexto el
último brote digamos más intenso que
vivió el país fue en 2017 y en ese
momento los casos de dengue habían sido
unos 70.000 contagios es decir que ya
sólo en 2023 estamos cerca de duplicar
estas cifras a pesar de que es verdad
que las autoridades sanitarias dicen que
por suerte Pues están disminuyendo en la
mayoría de las regiones más afecta los
casos eso no quita que todas estas zonas
Como por ejemplo las del norte de Perú
que son de las más afectadas haya días
donde los diagnósticos son 1400 casos
diarios con los problemas de
infraestructura de saturación de los
hospitales que esto conlleva no el
dengue solo llega a ser mortal en un
2,5% de los casos normalmente pero no
atenderlo a tiempo suele aumentar la
proporción de casos de dengue
precisamente Esto es lo que están
criticando muchas voces en el Perú que
están llegando muchos casos muchos
cuadros cada vez más graves a los
hospitales y además está afectando
especialmente adultos mayores personas
con comorbilidades como la diabetes o la
hipertensión y también a los niños como
veíamos en las cifras Exactamente no
está gestión esta falta de respuesta
rápida está siendo objeto de críticas
hasta para la presidenta Dina boluarte y
su ministra de salud Sí de hecho también
no el hecho de no haber podido anticipar
que iba a llegar esta crisis y que ahora
estén tomando medidas como fumigar que
solo sirve normalmente cuando como
medida de prevención pues es una de las
críticas que están recibiendo Pero bueno
precisamente para que nos contara más
sobre esta situación contactamos a
Francisco Zacarías el corresponsal de
France 24 en Lima y esto fue lo que nos
contó
con más de 137 mil casos y más de 200
fallecidos Perú vive la peor epidemia
del dengue en regiones como piura al
norte del país los hospitales están
colapsados y faltan médicos el sistema
sanitario enviará desde Lima
profesionales de salud y medicinas para
atender la emergencia con un hospital
itinerante Perú es un país epidémico de
dengue sobre todo en la selva y la costa
Norte el Ministerio de salud de sanación
cuenta con información para prevenir la
enfermedad y tratarla diversos sectores
critican que el Ministerio de salud y
los gobiernos regionales no actuaron
debidamente para prevenir en lo que va
del año han fallecido más peruanos por
dengue que durante el 2017 por eso el
reproche que hace días atrás la ministra
de salud Rosa Gutiérrez dijo que en 15
días iba a derrotar la epidemia la
posición de muchos peruanos Es que la
ministra renuncie en esa línea
congresistas de diferentes agrupaciones
políticas han presentado una moción de
interpelación contra Rosa Gutiérrez
quien ha sido respaldada en el cargo por
la presidenta Dina boluarte al respecto
la ministra Gutiérrez afirma que no va a
renunciar pero algunos legisladores como
la fujimorista rosángela bárbarán
consideran que si la ministra de salud
No ejecuta una acción efectiva para
combatir la epidemia del dengue debería
dejar el cargo
mar y además la llegada inminente del
fenómeno del niño podría empeorar la
situación no sí como bien decías es un
fenómeno climático que ya lo tenemos
encima ya empezó oficialmente que afecta
al continente americano pero en Perú
particularmente afecta con más calor y
con más lluvias y en este caso las
autoridades sanitarias han dicho que
precisamente esta llegada del fenómeno
podría aumentar hasta en un 15% los
contagios que ya se darían sin este
fenómeno digamos en el caso del dengue
porque precisamente es el calor las
lluvias la humedad lo que favorece la
reproducción del mosquito que pues luego
puede contagiar está enfermedad y además
es interesante porque esto ya ha venido
pasando en Perú es decir este brote se
explica en gran parte porque ya están
situaciones climáticas de más calor se
ha alargado digamos la temporada más
cálida porque ya han habido lluvias
torrenciales recordemos el ciclón yaku
por ejemplo no que es un ejemplo de eso
y Cómo afecta además también a las zonas
donde hay menos saneamiento que son
precisamente entonces donde más casos de
dengue se dan es además un ejemplo
clarísimo de cosas que venimos hablando
Ya muchas veces que es este impacto de
las condiciones climáticas y del cambio
climático en enfermedades transmisibles
por vectores como los mosquitos el
dengue y este brote de dengue en Perú es
un ejemplo clarísimo y mar esto En un
momento en que esta no es la única
crisis sanitaria que atraviesa Perú no
no la verdad se les suman las crisis y
las emergencias que están afrontando en
este momento hace poco comentábamos en
esta misma sección que Perú está en una
emergencia epidemiológica por los casos
de sarampión y también de polio y Esto
fue porque detectaron un caso de polio
por primera vez en 30 años prácticamente
en una de las regiones amazónicas del
Perú y también por el aumento de casos
de sarampión ambas enfermedades son
prevenibles con las vacunas y
precisamente a raíz de las
interrupciones del covid-19 de las
críticas que existen recientemente no
alrededor de las vacunas pues no la
mayoría los niños no se están
inmunizando no se están inmunizando
tanto como antes y esto hace no que
puedan reaparecer este tipo de
enfermedades el gobierno peruano tiene
el objetivo de vacunar a 2,5 millones de
niños menores de 5 años ayer supimos que
ya habían repartido uno coma ocho
millones de dosis de las vacunas por
ahora pero bueno veremos si
efectivamente se responde desde las
administraciones no con la rapidez que
se precisa en este tipo de casos donde
se juntan tantas emergencias mar pues
muchísimas gracias por acercarnos la
situación sanitaria de Perú nos vemos
mañana con más salud nos vemos mañana
Rosa